for more on all things politics we turn
to fill a bump national correspondent at
the Washington Post Phillip good morning
morning sir
let's start with Syria as Weejun was
just reporting because we we have some
confusion here it seems between the
president and the State Department as to
what's gonna be happening in Syria right
so the president Trump has fairly true
to form at a campaign style within this
week said essentially he's going to
withdraw troops from Syria the Post
reported yesterday actually that he had
had some conversations he'd spoken with
defense secretary mattis he had asked
for a plan for that withdrawal to be
drawn up it's interesting though because
he had consistently criticized President
Obama for having left Iraq too early and
creating space for the Islamic state and
some of the concern apparently within
the Defense Department is that by
withdrawing from Syria you again to
create a vacuum into which either diesel
on the state could step or give more
space to Russia and so when the
president Trump says we should let
others take take over in Syria take
control of what's going on there he said
on the campaign trail which is just like
Russia deal with Syria so it's not
really clear who he intends to actually
fill that void but it's clear that he's
not happy that we're there I mean is
there a sense that he's just okay with
handing over the keys to Russia and Iran
on Syria at this point it's hard to say
but I mean he said that explicitly on
the campaign trail he said why are we
dealing with this why can't we just like
Russia deal with this and so you know
it's obviously we can't always take
everything he said on the campaign trail
and apply it to his presidency but it's
not clear and I think that one of the
points that that is worth repeating is
that normally when a president is making
a announcement about something to the
scale of we're withdrawing troops from a
place where we are
you know participating in supporting
combat operations it's not done sort of
on the cuff at a rally and leaving for
example the State Department somewhat
caught off guard speaking of Russia
which we were just talking about we have
we of course this week had a major
tit-for-tat diplomatic war with the
Russians and we now have a new national
security advisor John Bolton what what
difference do you think that's gonna
make in in foreign policy at this point
so Bulls track record as is probably
most people are aware is that he is much
more hawkish than a lot of folks who
within the foreign policy infrastructure
that doesn't mean that we're gonna rush
into war with Russia but it may mean
that that he is advocating within the
administration for
fermer steps in what we've seen so far
there's a lot that can be done you can
apply more direct sanctions to to
Vladimir Putin and his allies you can
apply sanctions to the energy industry
we could do some of the same sorts of
cyber meddling that there that we
believe they did during the 2016
election there's a lot that can be done
it's not clear if Bolton will be
advocating for that within the White
House but the big picture question the
overarching question that is always
applied to our interactions with Russia
since January 20th 2017 is what
President Trump himself wants to do and
he's always shown reticence to take any
firm action so it's gonna be interesting
to see if that changes fascinating to
hear about the EPA Pruitt's story
exactly where he stayed where is that
headed what do you think's gonna happen
with that that's a great question I mean
we've seen other members of this
administration who have faced the boot
for such things Tom Price who's former
head of the Department of Health and
Human Services took all those expensive
flights and then Doug losing his job but
Pruett has really been one of the people
in the administration who is driven
really hard on what Donald Trump wants
to see which is rolling back a lot of
environmental regulations creating a
space for the energy industry within the
government he's the head of the EPA and
it's been infuriating to a lot of
environmentalists a lot of environment
also be very happy to see Scott Pruett
gone I'm not sure though if Donald Trump
is going to take a hard line with Pruit
simply because he's been so effective at
doing what Trump wants him to do
fascinating week there's always so much
more to get to Phillip we could we could
talk all morning thank you so much for
joining us so bump